you appear people I punch above my
weight
what do you want grant your head on a
plate
you
oh my god youtubers they just released
some gameplay from injustice ooh it's
amazing let's break it down the biggest
surprise is Grodd Atrocitus a whole
bunch of characters that weren't
anywhere near the first game they said
that was their big goal with this game
was just a widen the field enormously in
addition to expanding the story too so
story mode is going to be way bigger and
the list of starting characters is going
to be way bigger than the original game
now I know the original game released a
bunch of extra characters with DLC there
were skins for the mobile version of the
game there'll be some of that too that
there's always going to be DLC but some
of the new features that they kind of
teased in the last little teaser trailer
was the customizable armor the idea that
it's customizable wasn't really evident
from that so when you see all these
other characters wearing their armor
you'll be able to customize that and
mix-and-match things through the game
that'll be part of the upgrade process
but I love the way this trailer teases
some of the finishing moves like you
have Batman dragging Superman around
with a batplane you have supergirl vs.
Atrocitus which is a big thing in the
comics so there will be a lot of bleed
from the comics even though I know they
did an injustice comic tie in with the
first game there'll be some of that too
if you really like the tie-ins with the
first game Aquaman having a giant shark
eat king Grodd I know a lot of you asked
me on twitter is that king shark can
Aquaman control king shark not really
but I do like the idea because they did
that on the flash TV show this year
where king shark was jumping through the
water trying to eat the flash but get
hype and I know a lot of you have asked
if I'm going to do gameplay videos for
this whenever it comes next year yeah
I'll totally do videos for it most of
the gameplay like the pure gameplay will
be on my game channel this is called
Charlie's dreams there's a link for it
in the description I have a twitch
channel too so i might stream some of it
i know i don't scream a lot right now
most of the stuff that I do isn't very
stream friendly like it requires me to
watch something and then I go make a
video about it video game content is a
little bit different so there'll be some
fun stuff next year but because this was
a huge surprise there was a spider-man
video that I was going to make I'll just
push that till Monday because tomorrow
is basically like a game of thrones day
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and because this is so
awesome i'm just gonna go ahead and
start a new round of the giveaway now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post a DC video so that'll
probably like Monday or Tuesday
depending on what ends up happening
there are any really big surprises from
e3 in the next week I'll totally do
videos for it I know normally I don't do
video game videos on this channel but if
it's big enough and it has something to
do with the comics I'll totally do video
for it I will be posting on Facebook and
Twitter if you don't know where I am on
Facebook and Twitter there are links for
that in the description too i think
they're all the way at the bottom of the
description so many awesome surprises
this week why you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for the
injustice trailer and you can click here
for my first Voltron video if you don't
know about Voltron it's on netflix watch
the video then watch it on Netflix thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
Oh